[Music]
it is the bestselling book in history no
volume ever written has been more loved
and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previous
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 800 835
6747 once again that's 800 835
6747 now here's your host from amazing
facts International Pastor Jean Ross
Hello friends how about an amazing fact
Jack was a black Retriever who lived in
Swansea Wales in the
1930s one day in 19 1931 the dog spotted
a 12-year-old boy swimming in the river
TW near the city do Docks but the boy
was struggling against the strong tide
and couldn't keep his head above the
water realizing the boy's predicament
Jack jumped into the water swam over to
the drowning boy and pulled him to
safety Jack then made it his duty to
patrol the harbor and the river looking
for people who had accidentally fallen
from the docks or who had gotten
themselves into trouble while swimming
in the river short shortly after his
rescue Jack saw a person who had fallen
from the docks who didn't know how to
swim the dog jumped into the water
grabbed the drowning Man by his coat and
pulled him to safety after this rescue
the local Council awarded him a silver
collar the dog became the town's
self-appointed lifeguard and was always
ready to come to the rescue of those who
found themselves in trouble in addition
to saving people Jack also saved two
other dogs from drowning that had fallen
off the city docks and didn't know how
they were to find their way out all in
all get this Jack is credited for saving
at least 27 people from drowning this
friendly canine became a local celebrity
and a hero and after he died in 1937 a
memorial was erected in his honor in the
town of Swansea the inscription on the
monument says never had mankind more a
faithful friend than thou who off thy
life did land to save some human soul
from Death did you know friends that the
Bible says that Jesus is a friend that
sticks closer than a brother that's
Proverbs
18:4 and in John
15:13 Jesus said greater love has no one
than this than to lay down one's life
for his friends you see friends Jesus is
both our best friend and our savior if
you'd like to learn more about this
great Plan of Redemption if you perhaps
don't know Jesus as your best friend and
you'd like to get to know him more we
have a free gift that we'd be happy to
send you it's one of our study guides
here at amazing fax and it's called
saved from certain death and all you'll
need to do in order to receive that is
to call the number 800
83567 47 that has our free offer line
and ask for that study guide It's called
saved from certain death we'll be happy
to send it to you here in North America
if you're outside of the US just go to
our website just amazingfacts.org and
you'll be able to read it there as well
and uh my name is Jean Ross Pastor Doug
Bachelor is out this evening but working
the phones is Pastor Elden and we are
delighted that he's here kind of helping
answer Bible questions and working the
phones for us so welcome Pastor Elden
good evening it's exciting to be here
all right well thank you for joining us
here why don't we begin with the word of
prayer and uh then we'll go to our Bible
questions Heavenly Father we thank you
you for the opportunity that we have to
be able to come and answer questions
through this program we ask for the holy
spirit's guidance as we maneuver Through
the Bible with all these different
questions continue to lead us guide us
convict us of the truths we hear we pray
all these things in Jesus name amen amen
you know Pastor alen it's always
exciting to read stories and there's a
lot of them I we just picked one but
there are many stories about animals
particularly dogs and dolphins for some
reason that have saved the lives of
people they seem to have this Instinct
that they can recognize when someone's
in trouble and they're able to come to
their rescue and many of them have you
know they've risked their own lives to
save you know the life of a human being
well of course I think this instinct to
save and this this concern for others is
really something that God has placed in
the heart not only of man but of some of
the animals it seems and it's a
reflection of God's great love for us
amen the Bible says for God the world
that he gave he gave his only begotten
son that whosoever believes in should
not perish but have everlasting life and
as we mentioned at the beginning of the
program we've got a free gift that we
would love to send people if you're
wondering about how you can't be saved
or maybe you just need to be reminded of
the good news of Salvation you want to
read the study guide It's called save
from certain death now Pastor Alden I
know you've got some phone lines there
what number do people call again if they
want to get the free offer that number
is 1 1800
747 very good thank you also if people
want to get it via a digital download
there is a text number we have for them
they can text if they're in the United
States or one of the territories or
Canada they can text pound 250 okay and
but if they're outside then you would
have to go to our website which is
amazingfacts.org excellent thank you
very much all right well I think we are
ready for our Bible questions so who's
our first caller this evening our first
caller is Britney and she has a question
regarding the feast days hi Britany
welcome to the Bible answers live you on
the air yeah my question is are
Christians supposed to K with Fe all
right are Christians supposed to keep
the feast well in the Old Testament you
know this is a common question that
people have in the Old Testament there
are four different types of law that you
can read about in the Old Testament the
one is the moral law that is The Ten
Commandments and of course the Bible
tells us that sin is the transgression
of the law and what's law is that well
that's the Ten Commandment law the first
four have to do with our relationship
with God the last six have to do with
our relationship to our fellow man but
in addition to that law we call that the
moral law there are three other sets of
law found in the Old Testament the other
one is what we call the Civil laws the
Civil laws were the ones that governed
the nation of Israel under theocracy
meaning that God was their King and God
was communicating his will to the people
through the high priest and uh that
whole system um of course we don't have
a theocracy today but the principles
that were out there countries that
follow those principles they typically
are blessed and and there is um Law and
Order in that country another set of
laws that we see in the Old Testament is
what we call the health laws and the
health laws gave practical principles on
how a person could be healthy and not
only does it talk about what you should
eat and what you shouldn't eat but also
gave practical principles on washing
your clothes staying clean washing your
hands especially if you touch something
that is dead uh certain animals or
certain fun GUI that was even seen in
the home or in dishes how that had to be
dealt with so they were practical Health
principles that we read about in the
Bible many of those principles we
actually follow today but they that
right there in the word of God then the
next category the last category of law
is what we call the ceremonial laws now
the ceremonial laws were given to point
to Jesus part of the cermonial law
included the sacrificial system Jesus is
the Lamb that takes away the sins of the
world uh that came to an end when Jesus
died on the cross in addition to the
sacrificial system and the levitical
priesthood and the sanctuary and its
services there were also certain what we
call festivals or feasts that were
connected with that ceremonial law they
were given to Moses at Mount Si for
example the Passover the Passover began
after the children of Israel left Egypt
and they all pointed to Christ or to his
ministry or to his work actually today
we believe Pastor alen that we're living
in the antitypical day of atonement CHR
one of those days was the day of
atonement the day of yon kipur there in
the Hebrew and we believe that the type
of that as matter its antitype and we're
living in this special time of cleansing
this judgment that was Illustrated in
the Bible so we do no longer no longer
do we need to keep the specific days but
there are principles I think relevant in
the feast this of course is separate
from the seventh day Sabbath which is
actually part of the moral law correct
it's not part of the ceremonial law all
right thank you Britney you know years
ago um pastor Joe Cruz wrote A A booklet
and if she would like to ask for it if
you ask for feast days in the Sabbath oh
you can get this free offer and you can
call 1 800 835 67474 all right thank you
yes get the book if you want to learn
more about the feast days and how they
relate to us as Christians today take a
look at that book 800 835 6747 and the
book is called feast days and the
Sabbath feast days and sabbaths all
right excellent thank you we have Larry
calling in from Oregon first time and
Larry's got a question about Pride
hi Larry welcome to the
program good evening pastors yeah thanks
for
calling yes thank you got a question on
1 John
2:16 uh lust of the Flesh and lust of
the eyes are pretty self-explanatory but
I'm having a little issue on uh pride of
life uh in comparing Mark 7:22 with this
where do you cross from an acceptable
Pride to a sinful Pride all right very
good well when it comes to Pride in
general typically the word pride has a
negative connotation to it it's usually
self-exaltation and we're not to promote
ourselves we're not to um try and make
ourselves look better than others often
pride is associated with pushing
somebody else down to try and Elevate us
higher than them however value having a
value recognizing our value in the eyes
of God is different God wants us to
realize that we are precious in his
sight Jesus died to save us so the
Christian should have a clear
understanding of his value but it's not
just his value it's the value of
everyone else because Jesus died for the
whole world so we are not better than
anyone else however seeing that such a
price has being paid for us we ought to
want to live a life that brings honor
and glory to God in all that we do so
yes pride is one of those sins you know
that was the sin that really LED Lucifer
in the beginning right and the whole
rebellion and of course pride is still a
very a dangerous thing today it sort of
governs our world in areas of
entertainment in politics in sports
pride is often the motivating factor for
why people do what they do and as a
Christian we need to be careful of that
because you know selfishness or Pride
that is the carnal mind that's the
carnal heart we say we want to say Lord
Make Me humble help me to recognize my
value in your sight but keep me humble
we've got to remember it's not about us
yeah it's about him right that's right
so the moment it becomes about us yeah
we're going down you know I'm thinking
of the verse Pastor Ellen maybe you can
look it up where it says Jesus made
himself of no reputation but he humbled
himself and he took upon himself the
form of a servant now of course Jesus
one with the father gave back the sep of
the universe into his father's hand came
to this sin polluted Planet humbled
himself he didn't come to the Palace of
the king he was born in a manger and
Jesus came to give an his example of
living a humble life the king of kings
and to die as an atoning sacrifice for
us sins so beautiful illustration of
what true humility and kindness is all
right who do we have next we have Shane
calling from Arizona and he's got a
question about Adam and Eve all right
Shane welcome to the
program oh hi
um I know that the
square uh symbolizes Adam's Rib I know
that Adam and Eve
manufactured um aprons is Adam and Eve
the first introduction of artificial
synthetic technological light on Earth
okay well yeah that's a good question
you know when it comes to Adam and Eve
you know the story you read it there in
Genesis chapter 3 where Adam and Eve had
this God created this beautiful garden
created Adam and Eve God was the one who
first performed a surgery the Bible says
that God put Adam to sleep and took a
rib from his side and with the rib God
created Eve and brought Eve to Adam uh
but after they sinned we find that they
went and hid themselves from the
presence of the Lord and they made
artificial clothing now they might have
been clothed and we think the Bible
gives us evidence for this they might
have been clothed in a garment of light
the Bible says that we're creating God's
image and Psalms tells us that God
covers himself with light as a garment
so we believe Adam and Eve were clothed
in these beautiful uh garments of light
they lost that light after they sinned
and then they realized their their shame
and their nakedness a symbol of their
guilt and they made aprons of these fig
leaves and of course then Jesus came and
he made coats of skin but that required
the sacrifice or the death of a lamb and
that was prefigure of Christ and what
Jesus would do so we could be clothed
with his righteousness so the first
record that we have of clothing making
you might say in the Bible yeah goes
back to Adam and Eve and they were
trying to just hide their guilt and
shame and I think a lot of what people
are doing today still just in the things
that have been made the Technologies and
all of the things there's some good
things in technology and advances in
medicine all the rest of it but some of
it is used for bad purposes to hide
guilt so uh we need to confess our sins
ask God to forgive us it's also
interesting when you look at what they
covered themselves when Adam and Eve
sinned they realized that they sin they
covered themselves with leaves fig
leaves but that was not enough for
modesty so God had to cover them a
little bit more so they could Co skin
right yeah and you know there's a lesson
in that for us Christ's righteousness
covers Us from head to you might say we
need to be completely clothed in
Christ's robe of righteousness none of
our self-righteousness but his
righteousness and then also interesting
throughout scripture then fig leaves or
the Fig Tree is often associated with
man's attempts to save himself that's
why Jesus cursed the Fig Tree you read
about that in the gospels all right who
do we have next Gary's calling from
Illinois and he's got a question
regarding the law hi Gary welcome to the
program hi is this right when the law
was given it was Ten Commandments ments
and book of Moses Commandments carved in
stone while book of Moses was written in
the book Commandments placed uh in Ark
of the Covenant while book of Moses is
not and that's why the law that we're
not under is book of Moses is that right
yeah you right on there so when it came
to the Ten Commandments you'll remember
the account the Bible says that God
called um Moses up onto the mount and
gave him the first time Ten Commandments
written on tables of stone but then as
you remember remember the children of
Israel rebelled right after this and
when Moses came down off the mount
because the people were breaking the Ten
Commandments that he had just received
from God he threw down the Ten
Commandments and they broke and then God
said all right now you C off some Stone
and then come up and I will write the
Ten Commandments on it so there was a
second plate of stones after the The Ten
Commandments were carved by the Finger
of God on these these tablets of stone
they were placed then in the Ark of the
Covenant now in addition to being in the
ark The Ten Commandments are inside the
ark there was also a Rod that was
eventually placed there uh that budded
representing that God had chosen Aaron
and his family to be the priests and
then there was also a pot of Mana that
was placed in the ark a symbol of God
sustaining the children of Israel and
bringing them up out of slavery out of
Egypt and leading them to the promised
land then in addition to the Ten
Commandments there were as we mentioned
before some of the statutes we spoke
about the ceremonial law these things
were all written even how they were to
deal with property and inheritance and
uh marriage and all kinds of social
things were written down part of What's
called the law of Moses and that was
placed on the side of the Ark now the
law of Moses Paul tells us in the New
Testament that was contrary to the
Gentiles because there were some
specifications in the law for example uh
if you were not a Jew if you were not
circumcised you couldn't come into a
certain area surrounding the temple
itself even in the days of Jesus there
was a mark in the courtyard and if you
were a gentile and you stepped over that
Mark you could be killed and Paul says
that was the law contrary to us meaning
contrary to the Gentiles but Christ did
away with that having nailed that to the
Cross so the ceremonial law met its
fulfillment in the death of Jesus then
Paul says now he who has faith in Jesus
he is the Seed of Abraham so it doesn't
matter what you know your nationality
might be or what your genes are your
family inheritance if you have faith in
Jesus your Abraham seed airs according
to the promise that's good news we have
free offer on that lesson six called
written in stone the LA God thank you
great lesson absolutely and they can get
that if they call 1800 835
6747 okay great again it's called ritm
in stone it's one of our amazing fact
study guides and you know friends we'll
just take a moment to mention this if
you have not yet taken advantage of the
amazing fact Study Guide Series it's a
whole set of Bible lessons it is great
you can do it online we can actually
send it to you through the mail you can
fill in the answer sheet send it back so
those of you have not yet gone through
the amazing fact Study Guide Series just
ask for that when you call and they'll
be able to sign you up it's free take
advantage of it who do we have next we
have Jerry calling from Texas and he's
got a question regarding Dorcas hi Jerry
welcome to Bible answers
live hey thanks guys my question tonight
is how long was dor sleeping before
Peter raised her up because they had to
send from Jaa those two individuals the
Lydia the bring Peter how long was she
sleeping approximately yes um you know
back in those Bible back in Bible times
uh when somebody died you you couldn't
have the body around Long especially in
that climate in that area so maybe when
she start when she became very sick and
she started failing in health uh maybe
word began to spread that you know she
doesn't have too much time and maybe the
family and the friends need to need to
get get close uh verse 38 of Acts
chapter 9 says since Lydia or L was near
japa and the disciples had heard that
Peter was there they sent two men to him
imploring him that he would come without
DeLay So it appears that it wasn't too
far away from where Peter was I would
imagine within a Day's Journey at least
Peter was able to get over there you
couldn't keep a body open for more than
probably a day day and a half two days
at the most so it was in a short period
of time I know with the Hindus they have
I think eight hours and they have to
burn the body at that point right it's
so hot especially in that climate all
right thank you who do we have next well
we have Lee in Texas once again and has
a question regarding the Sabbath hi Le
welcome to the program yes my question
is when we're supposed to when God comes
back on the uh on new Heaven and new
earth yes how you might and we and we do
keep the the Sabbath on the new Earth
how are we supposed to be able to keep
something like that when there's no
passage of time okay good question
well first of all when the earth is made
new now let me just back up a little bit
to share with you the context here of
what we're talking about in the book
Revelation Revelation chapter 20 you
have a description of what we call the
10,000 years or the Millennium what
marks the beginning of that thousand
years is the second coming of Christ so
Jesus comes the dead in Christ are
resurrected the living righteous are
changed in a moment and the living
righteous are caught up along with those
who are resurrected and we go with Jesus
to heaven for a thousand years uh the
wicked are destroyed with the brightness
of Christ coming and the devil and his
angels are chained so to speak on the
earth referred to as the bottomless pit
during those thousand years at the end
of the Thousand Years the New Jerusalem
this is Revelation chapter 21 the New
Jerusalem comes down out of Heaven it's
at that point that Jesus will then set
his feet on the Mount of Olives and this
is in Zachariah the book of Zechariah
and the mountain will open up and form a
great Valley and the New Jerusalem will
come to rest right there in that Valley
uh there is what's called called the
Great White Throne judgment that then
takes place all the wicked are
resurrected they're outside the New
Jerusalem the righteous are inside the
city there is the final judgment and
then the wicked Mount their attack upon
the New Jerusalem this is Revelation
chapter 20 and fire comes down and
devours them and then after the fire
does its work of purifying the Earth
both of the devil his angels and the
wicked then the Bible says God creates a
new heavens and a new Earth wherein
dwells righteousness now when the Earth
is recre created it'll still be turning
uh it'll be a glorified Earth but we'll
still have days we'll still have nights
because the Bible tells us in Isaiah
chap 66: 23 and it shall come to pass
speaking about that time that from one
new moon to another and from one Sabbath
to another All Flesh shall come and
worship before me says the Lord so in
the earth made new we will still have
days the Bible does tell us though that
in the New Jerusalem itself there is no
need for the Sun because the glory of
God fills the New Jerusalem with light
but outside of the New Jerusalem yes
you'll still have the weekly cycle
you'll also have the moon traveling
around the earth because it talks about
months and somebody asked somebody once
asked why do we go up into the New
Jerusalem on a monthly basis well the
Bible also says that the Tree of Life
inside the New Jerusalem Bears 12 kinds
of fruit a different kind of fruit every
month so maybe we journey to the New
Jerusalem to taste that month's fruit
from the Tree of Life that's what the
Bible says so no the Sabbath will be
kept in the earth made new the Bible is
very clear on that we have that uh bible
study on the Colossal City in space
that's right all about the New Jerusalem
about heaven we'll be happy to send that
to anyone who calls and asks the study
guide is called a colossal City in space
and how do we get that lesson they can
call 1 800 835
6747 ask for the Colossal City in space
Also I think that can text they can text
number correct pound 250 in the United
States US territories in Canada but if
not go to our website amazingfacts.org
and you can ask for it there all right
thank you uh maybe we got time for one
more before the break Pastor alen who do
we have this is right up your Aly this
is Jose from Texas talking about 70E
prophecy okay great hi Jose welcome to
the
program evening pastors how you guys
doing doing well thank you thank
you I would like to know in uh Daniel 9:
26 where that timeline Falls within the
70 we prophecy okay yeah let me read it
for you uh for those who are listening
and we might have to give a little
background it says and after 62 weeks
Messiah shall be cut off but not for
himself and the people of the prince who
used to come shall destroy the city in
the sanctuary and the end thereof shall
be with a flood Until the End war and
desolations are determined so are you
wondering if if that 62- we time period
is part of the 70 weeks yes yes it is so
in the previous verse it says from the
decree to uh restore and rebuild
Jerusalem verse
25 uh know therefore and understand that
from the going forth of the command to
restore and rebuild Jerusalem until
Messiah the prince there shall be 7even
weeks and 62 weeks so you have a total
of 70 weeks 70 weeks consists of 490
days there are 360 days in a Hebrew year
so you got a total of 490 days within
that 4 and every day equals a year so
it's really a time period of 490 years
otherwise known as the 70 weeks and
within that 70 week period it's divided
up into smaller sections in verse 26 it
says after the 62 weeks so you have the
first seven weeks and the first seven
weeks or 49 years brought you to a point
after the decree was given in 457 BC
when they were able to finish building
the wall surrounding Jerusalem and then
you go forward another 62 weeks that
actually brings you to the end of that
69 nth week 483 years what event
happened it says the anointing of
Messiah the prince that was the baptism
of Jesus and that occurred in 27 ad so
the starting point is 457 BC the baptism
of Jesus is 27 ad then it goes on to the
next verse and it says in the middle of
the week he shall bring an end to the
sacrifice and offerings Jesus died in 31
ad he died on the cross brought an end
to the sacrifices and the offerings the
second part of verse 25 you might be
wondering about it says and the people
of the prince who is to come shall
destroy the city and the sanctuary the
people of the prince that is to come is
a reference to the Romans and this is
under Titus this event occurred in 70 AD
the Romans came and destroyed the
Jerusalem they destroyed the temple so
the first part of verse 25 is talking
about Jesus Messiah the prince the
second part of the verse is talking
about the destruction of Jerusalem in 70
AD you can also read about that in
Matthew 24 as well as in Luke where it
talks about when you see armies
surrounding the City then you know that
its desolation is near so that is a
great study one of my favorite passages
right here highlighting Christ It Was
Written some 500 years before the events
actually took place so it's just an
amazing time prophecy very specific
tells you when Jesus was to be baptized
when he was to be crucified and when the
probationary time for the nation of
Israel was to end in 34 ad we have a
study guide you can look that up it's
called right on time and it's all about
the 70 we Bible prophecy well friends
don't go away we got another half an
hour of Bible questions we'll be back in
just a
[Music]
moment stay tuned Bible answers live
will return
[Music]
shortly are you looking for a simple way
to share your faith if you've ever found
yourself Tongue Tied when trying to
explain what the Bible teaches about the
Sabbath the second coming or the
afterlife you'll love the new amazing
fax tracks these colorful tracks feature
easyto read type and are large enough to
grab everyone's attention but small
enough to fit in your pocket to carry
with you wherever you
go 11 key Bible teachings are available
now purchase a sample bundle to see what
fits your needs then buy them in bulk
and save equip yourself in your church
to reach your community with the
eye-catching amazing fax tracks amazing
fax tracks easy to read easy to share to
order your sample bundle call 8005382583
[Music]
sign up today for this free Bible study
course by calling 1844
21570 that's 1844 215
7000 have you ever wondered how to share
Bible truth with your family friends
neighbors or co-workers in a powerful
yet simple way now you can send amazing
facts popular and attractive sharing
magazines right to their door
anonymously these 12 colorful magazines
present key Bible truths in an easy to
understand way to sign up someone you
love for the one-year subscription just
call
7275 or visit AF bookstore.com
Can't Get Enough amazing fax Bible study
you don't have to wait until next week
to enjoy more truth filled programming
visit the amazing facts media library at
aftv.org at aftv.org you can enjoy video
and audio presentations as well as
printed material all free of charge 24
hours a day 7 days a week right from
your computer or mobile device visit
aftv.org
[Music]
Jerusalem the city of Peace has been a
place of unending Conflict for centuries
many now believe that Jerusalem will
soon take Center Stage again but what
does the Bible say the fall and Rise of
Jerusalem presents the vital history you
need to know about Jerusalem and its
role an end time Bible prophecy this
amazing facts edition of the classic
volume the great controversy is the
perfect sharing book get your copy at AF
bookstore.com
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 700
p.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific time to
receive any of the Bible resources
mentioned in this evening's program call
800 835
6747 once again that's 800 835
6747 now let's rejoin our hosts for more
Bible answers
live Hello friends and welcome back to
Bible answers live this is a live
interactive International Bible study
want to welcome those who are joining us
not only here in North America but
Pastor Elden we got people watching on
YouTube on Facebook on amazings TV and I
believe it's been rebroadcast on some
other networks and more than 200 I think
250 now landbased radio stations carry
bible answers live so if you're
listening to this program
welcome if you're watching on YouTube or
Facebook welcome my name is Jean Ross
Pastor Doug Bachelor is away this
weekend but uh God willing he'll be back
next week but helping me here on Bible
answers live is Pastor Elden and Pastor
Elden you're doing a great job he's not
new to doing Bible questions he's been a
pastor for many years answered a lot of
Bible questions so we are grateful to
have him here all right who is our next
caller well we have Steve Steve's in
Oregon he's got a question regarding the
second coming and what happens when
Jesus comes all right let's see if we
can get Steve Steve welcome to the
program all right thank you for taking
my call prior to the Thousand-Year
Millennium when Jesus will return CPT
scripture says every eye will see him
back in the last Millennium I was in the
Navy assigned to a nuclear submarine for
months at the time um under sea without
servicing as are today's Sailors in the
sub Duty how will they see him coming in
the sky being submerged under tons and
tons of water boy you know Steve that is
a great question that's the first time
I've heard that you know often people
ask how will everybody see Jesus when
they come of never heard somebody asked
what about those in the submarine of
course you're right it will be different
but I think there's going to be so many
natural disasters the Sea's going to be
an upheavals there's going to be
earthquakes there's going to be so much
going on at that time uh maybe these
submarines are going to surface at the
time uh you know I don't know for sure
but the Bible does say that at some
point everyone will see him now of
course there are going to be people in
the submarine who are quite possibly
saved we don't know you know who's going
to be saved and who's going to be lost
at the end God's still going to be able
to save them even though they in the
submarine but I don't know we'll have to
wait and see you know what about the
blind people will they see Jesus coming
well we know those who are saved of
course they are changed in a moment in a
twinkling of an eye and they get these
Immortal bodies they won't be blind
anymore but what about the wicked so I
think the Bible there in Revelation 1:7
is talking in general terms meaning that
everyone that can see will see Jesus
when he comes again the world's also
going to be in great upheaval at that
time uh yes so I don't know how many
submarines are going to be below water
in the water during that time period
because it's going to be pretty chaotic
the Bible says there's great earthquakes
entire Islands inhabited Islands
disappear so it it'll be very different
than what we known now but that's a good
question yeah we'll have to wait and see
thank you Steve we have Nicole in
Michigan she's got a question about what
we can eat hi Nicole you're on Bible
ansers live Hi pator how are you doing
well thanks good I have a question about
Genesis 9 verse3 when it talks about um
when Noah and his family came out came
out of the Ark and the Bible says that
they can eat everything that came out of
the Ark now I know that we're the
unclean thing we're not supposed to eat
unclean Meats but why does that text
okay say that what what exactly is it
saying a good question well let me read
it for those who might not have their
Bibles in front of them I think you
thinking of Genesis 9:1 it says so God
blessed SN and his sons and said to them
be fruitful and multiply and fill the
Earth this is After the flood they
coming out of the Ark and the fear of
you and the dread of you shall be on
every beast of the earth and on every
bird of the air on all that moves upon
the Earth and upon all the fish of the
sea they are given into your hand verse
three says every moving thing that lives
shall be food for you I have given you
all things even as the green herbs now
when it says every living thing shall be
food for you it's the rest of scripture
that helps us understand what exactly
with reference to the living thing is
God referring to the first thing we need
to recognize that before the flood we're
introduced to clean and unclean animals
because when it came to Noah and the
flood there were animals coming under
the ark you had the sevens of the clean
and you had two of the unclean the
sacrificial system had already been
established long before the flood it's
actually established with Adam and Eve
right there after they sinned and it was
clear they knew what was clean and
unclean because only clean animals could
be offered as a sacrifice so the
distinction between clean and unclean
was always there unclean animals were
never considered food at least not by
God's people for sure it didn't even
enter their mind it's like us today
there are certain animals that we would
never consider as being food in some
places you go in the world they can eat
just about anything that moves across
your plate but you know in other
cultures say no that's not food so it's
it's not stated in the verse you got to
read some of the other passages of
scripture but it's clear that Noah
understood that when he's talking about
the animals that he could eat it had to
be clean animals because the next verse
gives further instruction says you shall
not eat the blood so he understood
something about the health principles as
it related to the clean and the unclean
animals especially in connection with
the sacrificial even at the end of verse
three it says I've given you all things
even as the green herbs so can you eat
all of the herbs well pretty much I mean
I wouldn't want to pull a Nebuchadnezzar
and eat the grass or anything like that
there's probably some herbs that's not
good to eat or some plants true yeah
some are poisonous yeah so even having
to say yeah you can eat everything that
grows sort of thing well obviously that
doesn't mean you can eat everything that
grows there are some things you don't
want to eat that same principle would
apply even to the animals all right we
do have a study guide It's called God's
free health plan it talks about what the
Bible says some principles that we can
follow to be healthy and so take take
advantage of that it's it's God's free
health plan the number is
6747 and Pastor Elden if they want to
get a digital download of that what do
they text you can text pound 250 in the
United States and the US territories and
Canada if not go to amazingfacts.org and
we will send that to you okay thank you
who do we have next we have May in
Washington with wiconsin who's got a
question regarding false prophets hi May
you're on Bible answers live hi isn't it
true that the Bible States in Revelation
that the false prophet is really
actually a man and not a nation yes yes
now um when it comes to Bible prophecy
there are two things you need to bear in
mind a king often would represent a
nation so I'm actually doing a lesson
right now on Daniel chapter 11 we're
doing it with the church and talks about
the King of the North and King of the
South and there are times when it refers
to specific King but it can also refer
to the nation that the king represents
now the false prophet that we read about
in The Book of Revelation it is a
individual that represents a power it is
a religious political power in the last
days it is also a movement that takes
place in a nation and to be really
honest and specific we're talking about
an called Babylon and that's referred to
as the false prophet and it arises for
the most part in the United States it is
a counterfeit form of worship that takes
the churches by storm you know Pastor
Elden I think that's beginning to happen
even now where people are putting their
trust in an experience religious
experience instead of in the Bible and
they are trusting how they feel or what
a pastor is saying or the music or
something else instead of what does the
Bible say and this is a counter system
and it's rise but it's going to have
prominent leaders that'll actually push
both protestantism or apostate
protestantism aspects of that with
Catholicism and it'll come together with
the United States at the end so it's a
deep study there's a lot in there uh but
yeah the false prophet represents a
movement it represents people in that
movement but it's more than just a
person it's a movement the challenging
thing is sometimes we get so caught up
in this that we have our own ideologies
and and we're used to what I think what
I feel rather than what God says that's
right and so we have to kind of level
everything and say what does God say
because whatever God says we have to
take that as the truth that's the Bible
no matter what anybody else says well
you know in the time of the Reformation
during the time of Martin Luther uh the
controversy was who has final Authority
is it the church through its Traditions
or is it the Bible Martin Luther said no
it's the Bible Bible has final Authority
in other words the church needs to be
tested by the Bible doctrines have to be
tested by the Bible in the last days
there isn't it an effort to put final
Authority not in the Bible but now in an
experience that a person might have so
either way the devil's goal is to get
people to trust in something else than
what the Bible says solar scriptura that
was the Cry of the Protestant
Reformation all right great question
thank you may okay we have Gio calling
from Washington first time calling and
he's got a question regards to coveting
and stealing hi Gio welcome to the
program
hi good evening pastors yeah so as you
said I have a question on the Ten
Commandments yeah and the Ten
Commandments seem so perfect but the
last one seems a bit out of place and I
know it sounds strange but hear me out
when Jesus elaborated on the
Commandments which was in Matthew
somewhere he said something like being
angry with your brother is murder in
your heart and leting over a woman is
adultery in your heart because it's the
same thing in your mind right right so
isn't coveting just stealing in your
heart so it seems a slightly redundant
yeah yes well that's a good point you
know if you look at all of the last six
of the Commandments that have to do with
our relationship with our fellow man
it's almost impossible to break any of
those last six without first breaking
the 10th for example murder it probably
begins with some form of covetousness
which is the tenth commandment adultery
stealing begins with some form of
covetousness lying yeah it's probably
something you're trying to cover up
you're not being honest so um the the
tenth commandment sort of summarizes the
motivation behind all of the others it's
the only commandment amongst the last
six that have to do with your actual
heart with your thoughts with your with
your intents uh and I think that's why
it's such an important commandment uh
all of The Commandments hinge on a hard
experience because it's possible to keep
the letter of the law in other words and
this is what Jesus is saying you know
you've heard it say of all you shall not
kill but I say if you're angry with your
brother without a cause you're guilty of
committing murder in your heart so Jesus
is saying it's not just about the letter
of the law it's about the spirit of the
law now there might be some who say well
you know I keep the spirit of the law so
I don't have to keep the letter of the
law but how can you keep the spirit of
the law that says Thou shalt not be
angry with your brother without a cause
and yet murder him you can't so if
you're going to keep the spirit of the
law you're also going to keep the letter
of the law and if you're going to keep
the spirit of the law you're going to
keep the tenth commandment that says
Thou shalt not covered so the the last
commandment is really the one that talks
about the motivation behind all of those
last six Commandments does that uh make
sense
Gio yeah it does okay thanks so much for
your call yeah absolutely who do we have
next well we have David calling from
California he's got a question regarding
turning the other cheek hi David welcome
hi thank you for uh accepting my uh my
question um yeah so um the Bible talks
about turning the other cheat and and so
as a Christian
does that mean that uh we don't have a
right to defend ourselves from physical
harm or or sexual harm okay uh first of
all no it doesn't mean that we we need
to just uh you know go with whatever
comes our way uh that specific command
has to do with interpersonal
relationships meaning one with another
there are other laws that we find in the
Old Testament for example an eye for an
eye and a tooth for a tooth that
represents Justice and those are the
laws that were to govern the nation so
those are the Civil laws that govern the
nation and um there's nothing wrong in a
government holding criminals accountable
for their bad behavior and there's
nothing wrong in us uh reporting a
criminal who is doing something wrong
and hurting somebody else it's perfectly
fine for us to say you know what this
person is is problem matter of fact we
should do that um you know when we can
but when it says turn the other cheek
it's talking about uh holding resentment
an anger towards another person
especially if that person recognizes
that they've hurt you and they've asked
for forgiveness you need to let it go
you need to try and forgive it you say
Lord help me to forgive sometimes yeah
we might have to keep quiet if somebody
says something and just say you know I'm
I'm not even going to cause a fuss I'm
I'm not going to Stir It Up but that
doesn't mean that we need to place
ourselves in danger that that you know
Jesus said if you're persecuted in one
city flee to the other so there's
nothing wrong in doing what you have to
do to protect yourself and if you know
of other people that are being abused or
hurt or in a dangerous situation I think
the first thing we want to do is help
them get out of that situation so the
Bible is not endorsing somebody to
suffer especially if they suffering
physical abuse or you know serious
emotional abuse uh you can separate
yourself from that situation you're not
violating that Commandment that says
turn the other cheek does that does that
help
David yes thank you very much Pastor all
right thanks you call who do we have
next we have Glenn in Ohio he's got a
question in regard to one of the
prophecies in Zachariah hi Glenn
welcome good evening thank you for
taking my call yeah yeah my question
concerns
prophecies in Zechariah Chapter 5 and
chapter six in chapter five Zechariah
said he saw a flying scroll and then it
goes on and gives dimensions and
descriptions but it talks about three
women sitting in the leadline flu or the
leadline epha and I it doesn't make much
sense I've heard people stumble and
stumble over that what the women stand
for but if youal point the word Isa in
Hebrew and make it say Asia we now have
fire instead of women in those lead lias
and it's a perfect description of the
scud missile and the F4 Tomcat Fighter
the F4 Phantom and I just want then the
other one is zecharias chapter 6 one
starting in verse one a perfect
description of the attack from the Twin
Towers okay and I never hear people talk
about those things but is it possible
that these things are prophecies
fulfilled in the current events well yes
I think there are prophecies if you read
through Zechariah there are very
descriptive prophecies relating to
certain acts of judgment and they
culminate near the Judgment of the end
now could they refer to more than what
the symbol might mention perhaps you
know they are different ideas or
suggestions but if we're going to let
the Bible interpret itself then we need
to ask ourselves well in Bible prophecy
what does a woman represent or in Bible
prophecy what do these horses a red
horse and a black horse as you read what
do they represent now much of the
imagery that you find here in Zechariah
is actually used by John in the writing
of the Book of Revelation in Revelation
when he opens up the seals there is this
uh White Horse that he seen Galloping
and then a red horse then a Pale Horse
and then a black horse and it represents
different time periods of Christian
history different things that were
taking place uh a woman of course in the
Bible represents a church so we first
and foremost need to look at those
symbols and see how do they fit into
what's happening in our world also we
need to recognize that Zachariah is not
only talking about things you know in
2024 but he's referring to things that
have occurred throughout history
especially as we get closer and closer
to the end closer to our time so I'm a
little reluctant to just say well this
specific symbol here represents this
specific event in history unless there
is a lot of different passages of
scripture that make that very clear was
the Twin Tower attack significant I
think it was and here's why in just a
nutshell um it's interesting that um
Islam is mentioned in the Book of
Revelation you actually have the fifth
and the sixth trumpet describes the rise
of Islam during the time of Muhammad and
then during the time of the Ottoman
Turks and it seems there's quite a bit
of very description of this this power
rising up and I think it is interesting
you read a little bit of Daniel chapter
11 some suggest that maybe at the end of
chapter 11 the King of the South might
have some reference to some of the
Islamic Nations I mean some of that's
still in the future so we're going to
have to wait and see how all of these
these come together but to take it too
far literal I think we need to be
careful we we don't want to get we don't
want to get confused and go go down the
wrong path there are a broader prophetic
application for these different aspects
and Zachariah is a very detailed
prophecy so we don't have time to get
into all the details of it but great
question we'll go to Lynn over in
Arizona she got a question regarding um
Daniel chapter 8 hi Lynn welcome to the
program hey Pastor John RS yeah yeah my
name is ly Moore in Phoenix I'm a member
of the Camelback Church okay John's
Church yeah yeah I've just got a quick
question in Daniel chapter 8 Why was the
gohost facing Westward Eastward and
Southward and what was susham what was
he facing susham why is that Pastor okay
yeah let me talk about that I'm glad you
noticed that sometimes people miss those
those little minutia of Prophecy uh for
those who are listening Daniel chapter 8
describes uh Powers using animals for
example a ram is first described in
Daniel chapter 8 that is two horns the
one higher than the other that
represents the kingdom of Meo Persia
and then there is a goat that is seen
and the Goat Rises up towards the east
and towards the South and towards the
north meaning that this power Greece
would come from the West which it did in
relationship to Persia so the reason
when it talks about not touching the
Earth and it's coming it's coming from
the West Greece and Alexander the Great
came up from the West Persia was Persia
sort of Iran the Middle East the
Mediterranean Ian area um Mesopotamia
and so that's why the goat came from the
West moving to the east whereas Persia
rose up from the East and moved to the
West good question thank you who do we
have next we have Robert calling from
Washington Robert you got a question
regarding the sealed book of Isaiah hi
Pastor Rob hello good to good to hear
from you again yeah thanks for
calling you're welcome um I know I've
got a short time um
Isaiah 29 I believe it's verse 11 um
talks about a sealed book and sometimes
a a denomination wants to claim that as
as their book that was invented by a man
a while ago um but then I I I wonder you
know I I thought well maybe it's Daniel
because Daniel is a sealed book in the
Bible but then uh verse four talks about
um it
being uh from from the voice of a medium
or something it says so I'm guessing
it's not Daniel um so who so what is the
sealed book so this is a prophecy that
Isaiah is making and he's referring to
the people this would be the people of
Israel who did not receive the words of
the prophecy it was to them a sealed
book mean not meaning that the book per
se was sealed but the prophetic message
was sealed cuz if you read a little
earlier verse vers 9 it says pause in
Wonder this is Isaiah
29:9 um blind yourselves and be blind
for they are drunk uh but not with wine
they stagger but not with intoxicating
drink the Lord has poured out on you the
spirit of deep sleep and has closed your
eyes namely the prophets and has covered
your heads namely the Sears so at the
time because of a rejection of doing
right rejecting God's Commandments the
people didn't understand the prophecies
Isaiah is prophesying he was about 150
years well about a little less maybe 100
years before the Babylonian captivity
and judgment is coming upon Jerusalem
and the people seemed oblivious to that
they seem to be walking around as one
who is blind or those are intoxicated
and Isaiah is saying judgment is coming
and then Jeremiah is the next Prophet
who was actually there when Jerusalem
was conquered by Nebuchadnezzar he was
also warning the people but it seemed to
be a sealed book The Prophet just they
didn't receive it because they had
rejected they rejected doing the will of
God all right maybe time for one more we
have Chelsea she's got a question in
Florida regarding Hellfire Hi Chelsea
welcome to the
program Hi how are you both good thank
you yeah so my question basically is
about Revelation 20 verse1 um right now
I'm sitting with a group of friends um
who kind of grew up believing that
Hellfire is an actual Eternal burning
place um but um we're studying and also
you know using amazing facts study guide
which has been really helpful um but
when we got to Revelation 20:1 I
actually got a little stumped on it too
because um the last part of the verse
says um basically saying the devil the
Beast and the false prophet shall be
tormented day and night forever and ever
so they're thinking because this is you
know in the Bible that is taken
literally to mean that they're actually
tormented forever like let me say
something about that that's a good
question you know there are some
passages especially in the Book of
Revelation where it talks about forever
now we need to read forever in its
context in the Bible the word forever is
used as long as life shall last it does
not mean Eternal not always depends on
the context so in this context it's
speaking about the devil and his angels
are cast into the Lake of Fire they are
tormented forever meaning as long long
as they live now it doesn't mean they're
going to live eternally they're not
going to live forever but their torment
will last as long as their life lasts
why do we know that because after the
fire does its work it says they'll be
turned to ashes and then God creates a
new Earth wherein dwells righteousness
so they're not going to burn forever but
it does appear from the verse that the
devil and the wicked will at least
suffer a day and a night because it says
their torment will be day and night
forever meaning until they die so the
punishment will at least extend a day on
a night maybe more we don't know the
Bible doesn't say everyone at the end
will be rewarded according to or judged
according to their deeds and the devil
he Bears the responsibility for all the
sin that we see in the world ultimately
so he will be judged accordingly so the
phrase forever doesn't always mean
Eternal it means as long as life lasts
or consumed until all gone till it's
there's nothing left yeah it's like a
forever fireplace but in when the wood's
gone it's it's gone it's gone doesn't
burn anymore all right it's accomplished
this purpose well friends we want to
thank you again for calling those who
have called in I'm looking at the clock
we probably don't have time for another
call but as we mentioned before this is
a weekly International interactive Bible
study and we would welcome you to come
and give us a call next week if we
didn't get to you this week also want to
remind you if you haven't visited the
amazingfacts website recently take a
look just amazingfacts.org or.com it is
jam-packed with great resources you can
click on the the tab that says study
with us and you can learn so much more
now for those of you who are not on
satellite radio stand by because we're
going to be coming back with some of
your email questions so don't go away
too far we'll be right back in just a
moment thank you for listening to
today's broadcast we hope you understand
your Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing FAA
International a faith-based Ministry
located in Granite Bay California
Hello friends and welcome back we just
got about two minutes two and a half
minutes we're going to take some of your
email questions and Pastor Elden uh who
do people how do people get our get
their questions emailed to us what's
that email address well they can email
us at B questions amazingfacts.org we
made it as easy as we could right BL
questions.org and who do we have well
first question is Matthew chapter 151 17
to 20 seems to imply that all meat is
good to eat because what goes in the
mouth doesn't defile can you explain why
it does not mean that well here's a
story just to give you a little bit of a
background uh the religious leaders and
the Pharisees were accusing or
condemning the disciples because they
were eating with hands that had not been
washed so the issue in question wasn't
about what he you know clean or unclean
Foods the issue was eating food with
unwashed hands they were traveling they
grabbed something and they ate it and
they were making a big deal about it
they said this was a son and Jesus is
saying listen it's not it's not what
goes in and he's not talking about what
you eat he's talking about eating with
unwashed hands he says it's not that
that's important it's what comes out of
the heart all right so here is not a
statement just turning over and saying
well you can eat anything you want
you're not going to sick remember the
health principles are there because God
wants us to be healthy it's the prime
purpose rosn from Anguilla has a very
good question she asks will God answer
prayers if I don't pay tithe well God
answer prayers if we don't pay tithe
well you know the Bible does give a
blessing especially a financial blessing
for those who are faithful in trusting
God and giving and returning one1 that
is the tith it's 1110th and you know I
know so many stories of people who you
know stepped out in faith and said I'm
going to trust the Lord I'm going to pay
a tith and God blessed them not always
financially but there was a blessing
whether it was health or whe
relationships and so yes if we want
God's blessing and we want him to answer
those prayers well let's be faithful if
the holy spirit is convicting us of
something that we need to change we need
to make the change here's a quick one
here why doesn't God ask the shoes to be
removed when he encountered Abraham and
balum like he did with Joshua and Moses
yeah that's a good question you know it
seems that uh back in Bible times to
remove your shoes was an act of
reverence uh you were standing on Holy
Ground And when God appeared to Moses
said take the sandals off your feet part
of the reason why that was said was that
because God was identifying who he was
to Moses so there' be no doubt that this
is a Divine being this is God
communicating with him same thing when
God said to Joshua take the sandals off
your feet he was identifying who he was
and so taking the sandals off the feet
when God asked for it he was identifying
who he is as a person well friends that
is it for this week's edition of Bible
answers live we are so glad that you
joined us we look forward next week when
we'll be back to answer more of your
Bible questions God
bless Bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible
questions
h